♫
Most people hosting a
travel show want to do it.
They love doing it.
They have a sense of adventure.
That's not me.
Okay, this is crazy.
Oh god.
I think I'm feeling a
heart attack coming on.
I think they got the
wrong guy for the job.
I said to my agent,
"I'm definitely not the person for this show."
This is one cowboy that
will never have his own movie.
Woah.
[Horse whinnies]
This has taken me
all over the world.
Places I'd probably would
never had gotten to
if it hadn't been for the show.
The Maldives.
That was the longest trip
of all the places to get to.
A lot of flying.
Traveling, again.
Not one of my favorite things.
Woah.
Sweaty palms.
We wanted Eugene to
experience paradise
and to see how he felt
when he was here.
It's not as easy as sitting
on the couch with a bowl of popcorn.
I promise you you'll see
a lot of wildlife tonight.
[Eugene laughs]
Going into a jungle at night
in Costa Rica,
you know, looking for
poisonous snakes.
Let's say you get bit?
About an hour you're going to have.
- I have an hour to get to the hospital.
- That's right.
And the hospital is how far?
Fourty five minutes away.
Ahhh.
Why are we still here?
[Guide laughs]
Yeah, I'm still kind of
wondering why I'm doing it.
I was in Lapland.
The artic circle.
Ice floating.
I could not be more out of
my comfort zone
than I am right this second.
Reindeer meat.
Okay, here we go.
Then dog sleds.
Well, it's been nice knowing you.
[Handler calls out to dogs]
Oh my god.
South Africa. Wow.
I never really had any desire
to go on a safari or whatever.
I thought I had seen it all.
At the zoo.
Oh my!
I have to say, it's been
a bit of an eye opener for me.
Um, I haven't seen the view
yet to be honest.
I'm looking out now.
I'm doing some things
I would never have done.
That's a long way down Tony.
I'm set in a show that looks gorgeous.
The cinematography that's
going into making the series
is incredibly important,
we've got drone teams in the air,
we've got a great director of
photography with his camera team
and we want to transport the viewer
to these completly amazing locations.
There's a lot of talent and
a lot of great work
putting this show together and
making it look as good as it does.
In spite of the fact that
I'm the guy in the middle of it.
No matter what country I'm in,
I always know that
there's going to be some
laughs and some good times.
It's really about the people
and the culture.
You're kind of looking at
what everybody's doing
and finding out how
they're doing it.
Wow!
And what the background is
and what their history is.
A part of our culture and our language
will always be with you. Thank you.
This is amazing. This is,
this is really special.
So at my age right now
Oh god.
I think it's something I
needed to be forced to do.
I can't believe I did it.
[Laughs]
Woo.
And I've even surprised myself.
Mush you huskies!
Woo hoo hoo!
I'm the luckiest guy in the world.
[Laughs]
I'm glad it happened.
And I never thought I would say that.